a review of the chaos at wembley during
the euro 2020 final has found that there
were a number of very near misses that
could have led to fans being killed
while the match between england and
italy was marred by ugly scenes as 2000
supporters without tickets forced their
way into the stadium we can go live now
to wembley and speak to our sports
correspondent tom parmita
ian this should have been one of the
greatest moments in english football
since 1966 and that world cup victory
and while on the pitch they came so
close to winning the euro final against
italy of course losing out on penalties
you can't escape the debacle that was
happening in and around the stadium
around that event and this review by
baroness casey that has looked close up
at the trouble that occurred outside the
game has concluded that there was a
perfect storm of lawlessness and that
around 2000 ticketless fans managed to
storm the entrances at wembley and get
in
which created an incredibly dangerous
situation for them and other supporters
and she says that it's very fortunate
that nobody lost their lives or suffered
very serious injuries 17
breaches of the wembley gates were
recorded at different parts of the
stadium and there was chaotic violence
that was fueled by drink and drugs one
of the fans who contributed to this
review
said people were taking cocaine in front
of us and smoking drugs behind us my son
cried for most of the game now the
authorities just didn't anticipate the
levels of drunkenness of violence that
occurred outside on wembley way and in
the other areas around the stadium and
that is a major failing on behalf of the
police who didn't have enough numbers
there the stewarding operation and the
security around wembley it failed and
this is a report laying bare that
failure a failure to anticipate a
situation which you could really see
coming a lot of people could
predict
given what had happened in earlier games
in the tournament given the fact we've
just come out of the lockdowns
associated with covid19 given the fact
this is a home
major final taking place at wembley was
so easy for people just to turn up
try and
jib their way in that is the phrase that
football fans use jibbing their way into
the final getting in without a ticket
but two thousand of them managed to get
in and the report also highlights that
at the end of the game there were six
thousand fans outside wembley
trying waiting for a win in that penalty
shootout to get in and storm the stadium
so there could have been far
worse problems that night than there
were and that is laid bare in this
report the fa have welcomed the report
and have said in a statement from their
chief executive mark bullingham the fa
apologizes for the terrible experience
that many suffered within wembley on
what should have been a historic night
for the game
everyone at the fa was appalled at the
significant levels of crowd disorder
throughout the day on the 11th of july
the review makes clear that the
circumstances leading up to the match
led to a perfect storm of lawlessness so
in short this was a shameful episode
that many people thought had been
consigned to the dark days of english
football in the 70s and 80s but it
reared its head around this final
england versus italy on the 11th of july
and this report will make quite
difficult reading for the football
authorities and also of course it will
be read by fifa who are deciding whether
or not the uk and ireland should be
awarded a world cup bid in 2013. that's
still in the preliminary stages of going
ahead as a bid but you read this and you
think why would they and that is of
great frustration to the many many
england fans who support their team in
the right way and of course the england
players and gareth southgate who did
such an amazing job on the pitch let
down by a small minority of drunken a
horde of jobs that's how this report
explains
just what happened at wembley and why it
really matters because people could have
lost their lives